herzlich willkommen hier bei einer
spezialausgabe von die richtigen fragen
bei bild heute mit einem ganz besonderen
gast dem amerikanischen außenminister
mike kompon zum thema iran und
sanktionen aber natürlich auch zu der
vergiftung des russischen
oppositionellen
danke für die einladung
herr minister sie haben angekündigt dass
der iran auf der welt keine geschäfte
mehr machen soll
aber es gibt viele deutsche firmen die
mit dem iran geschäfte machen wollen und
auch die deutsche regierung sollte von
sanktionen nichts wissen was sind die
konsequenzen die deutsche firmen zu
befürchten haben wenn sie mit dem iran
geschäfte machen
das wichtig wichtige fragen heute nicht
es gibt viele unternehmen den usa
wieso eigentlich auch mit dem iran
geschäfte machen wollten schon es ist
ein großartiges volk mit einer langen
geschichte eine hohe kultur aber nein da
haben sie an regime dort im iran das
demokratisch und kleptokraten ist
angeführt von ayatollah dass ein
erhebliches risiko für die welt und die
größe und die usa werden nicht zulassen
dass das risiko steigt in dem sie mit
waffen handeln wir haben das gemacht
haben die un sicherheitsresolution 22 31
angewandt um sich zu helfen
sicherzustellen dass wir das verhindern
wir haben unsere kapazitäten verbessert
dass die un sanktionen auch durchgesetzt
werden gleichermaßen gerecht gegen
unternehmen überall auf der welt wir
wollen sicherstellen dass es kein geld
kein reichtum gibt für dieses regimes 40
jahre schon hat das gedauert da haben
sie terror geschaffen sie haben die
europäer ins risiko gesetzt um ihr kleid
haben eine bank die in iran geschäft hat
wird in den usa keine geschäfte mehr
machen richtig
die formale rolle der ankündigung
er wird noch kommen da werden klare
regeln veröffentlicht ist ghana
überrascht sein
man muss wissen was zu lassen was
unzulässig aber denken sie daran
kurz vor dem gemeinsamen aktionsplan das
sollte aktiviert wurde gab es von
sicherheitsresolution fast alle diese
aktionen werden wieder eingesetzt oder
kommen jetzt seid mit einheit schon
sieht das seit mitternacht es gibt ja
auch eine moralische komponente das
iranische regime hat gerade den ringern
avid auf kari hingerichtet dafür dass er
sich angeblich ein anti regierungs
protesten beteiligt haben soll
was sagen sie deutschen
vorstandsvorsitzenden die mit diesem
regime mit diesen mörderischen regime
geschäfte machen wollen punkte hinter
tag schauen sich deutschen unternehmen
werden verstehen dass die deutsche
wirtschaft weist das was sie im hinblick
auf die us-sanktionen machen müssen
diekamp regierung hat sich von jessica
abgewandt die deutschen unternehmen
verstehen die risiken wird sie sich
nicht an dem un sicherheitsresolution
halten das ist die bundesregierung die
so enttäuschend reagiert heißt das land
iran hat mord kampagnen durchgeführt
wenn die noch mehr geld und reichtum
hätten könnten sie waffen sind verkaufen
und kaufen
die bundesregierung will nicht dass der
jahn waffen kauft und verkauft aber es
gab kein plan keine alternative der
bundesregierung die usa werde die
führung behalten sie werden die
richtigen moralischen entscheidungen
treffen
nicht nur haben sie diesen ringer
umgebracht das ist die antisemitische
nation weltweit das ist eine nation die
nicht nur usa sondern auch den staat
israel zerstören will
aber solche volk wird das risiko
verstehen sie werden die bedrohung für
sie selber erkennen
das ist nicht ein land das den
sanktionen der resolution 22 31
entkommen sollte 19 oktober sollten sie
keine waffen mehr kaufen können
sie haben die rolle der deutschen
regierung gerade enttäuschend genannt
glauben sie dass die deutsche regierung
tatsächlich versteht was das iranische
regime mit israel vorhat sein müsste das
ist eindeutig meine ist das muss man
sich vor minuten immer wieder sagen die
iraner was ihre absichten sind
und dann sieht man die aktion die damit
übereinstimmen also ich glaube die ganze
welt kennt die natur des der bedrohung
der iranischen republik islamischen
republik der wert des nuklear abkommens
ist überschätzt wohin das ist
unglücklich sein gefährliches abkommen
über lesen die deutschen hatten
vorgeschlagen die europäer im fokus
sagen man sollte das einhalten
die usa sehen das anders wir werden
nicht zulassen dass sie reichte um geld
haben und herbert zu unterstützen wir
werden das nicht zulassen wir werden
nicht geld an die iranischen regime
gegeben werden
wir haben sicher stellen dass sie nie an
der atomwaffen bekommen wir haben die
möglichkeit die usa hat die möglichkeit
gegen diesen terror aufzutreten
eine große geschichte der vergangenen
tage war der versuchten mordanschlag auf
den russischen oppositionellen alexei
navalny und seitdem alexei navalny hier
in berlin im krankenhaus liegt es geht
ihm zum glück besser dreht sich die
debatte auch um die russische
gaspipeline nord stream 2 durch die
nicht nur gas nach europa fließen soll
sondern auch europäisches geld zurück an
russland und dieses geld trägt dazu bei
solche anschläge zu finanzieren was ist
ihre botschaft an die deutsche
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
wenn es um nord stream 22 punkte möchte
ich zeigen was er war nie angeht das ist
ziemlich klar
der einsatz chemischer waffen ist
inakzeptabel wir haben das immer klar
erwarteten unserer erwartung
kommuniziert an die russen dass sie das
untersuchen wir untersuchen können jetzt
zustande kam dass navalny vergiftet
wurde
wir wollen sehen dass sein pkw dann
später ende dieser woche ist ein
ergebnis 8 für die reaktion die usa
haben chemische waffen immer verurteilt
ein starke reaktion haben wir die
richtung gesandt die usa werden nicht so
reagieren dass das missverstanden werden
kann das muss gerecht und rechtlich
einwandfrei beurteilt werden wenn wir
die fakten das gilt auch für nord stream
wahl eindeutig wir haben gesagt gibt
russland geld das schafft risiken für
die europäische gasversorgung gas kommt
aus russland das bedroht auf die ukraine
viele deutsche haben tiefe emotionen wir
hoffen dass die mit 5
gabler nicht abgeschlossene forellen
verändert wird wir werden eine
kollektion bauen die das verhindert die
bundesregierung wird das irgendwann auch
so sehen was nach wanderwegen navalny
oder wegen echter sicherheitsfrage
auftauchen wenn man von russischem gas
abhängig wird ihre persönliche
vorhersage wird nord stream 2 zu ende
gebaut und wird zum 2 gas aus russland
nach europa bringen und europäisches
geld in den kreml
naja also im beruf der vorhersage der
weissacher bin ich nicht ich muss die
politik umsetzen und will die richtigen
ergebnisse also ich will nicht etwas
vorher sagen dankeschön herzlichen dank
und genießen sie den tag das war unser
interview mit dem amerikanischen
außenminister mike p hierbei die
richtigen fragen klare botschaften aus
washington auch an die bundesregierung
erstens die bundesregierung hat sich
bisher enttäuschend aus mike kompon
sicht verhalten beim umgang mit dem iran
beim umgang mit sanktionen gegen den
iran und der amerikanische außenminister
erwartet von deutschen firmen die
geschäftsbeziehungen mit iranischen
firmen weitestgehend einzustellen
solange das regime in teheran an der
macht ist und auch zu dem vergifteten
russischen oppositionellen navalny hat
mike kompon sich klar geäußert und
gesagt dass wenn besonders die opc veda
zu klaren ergebnissen kommt es genau so
eindeutige sanktionen geben sollte vor
allem was die gaspipeline nord stream 2
1 gibt damit herzlichen dank fürs
zuschauen hierbei die richtigen fragen
bei bild und bis zum nächsten mal